hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
the final part of do Damas discourse is
essentially the full initiation of
Socrates and the readers and of course
his hearers into one of the mysteries of
love revealing to us what love and its
essence is and could be what makes love
the way it is what it is how it is all
these sorts of questions remember too
that this is do tomoow speaking and
Socrates relating her words to the
audience that that he's got in front of
him in this symposium so she's already
talked about you know the desire for the
good and bringing forth upon the
beautiful now she's going to narrate of
an ascent through this what we can call
a ladder of Love's of erotic desire a
transformation that takes place at
multiple points and one thing that's not
present in this that I do want a signal
oftentimes people will talk about the
Platonic distinction between body and
soul and how antibody Plato is anti
flesh there's nothing of that here in do
Thomas speech so now that the body is
bad it's just that the body is not the
whole show as a matter of fact as we
move up the ladder as we become better
in
through the knowledge and through the
experience that love is affording us
what we're finding is the body just
doesn't matter quite so much
it is relativized you might say so she's
in effect initiating Socrates and
offering us we might call the outline of
initiation the the schema of it
something that is a verbal you know
representation of it without actually
being such an initiation because this is
represented as having to take place over
quite a bit of time so she begins by
talking about the beautiful body
we have erotic desire we have attraction
we have infatuation with a beautiful
body and that's okay we see somebody we
like them we feel you know all the
things that go along with love that
shouldn't be the end of the story
according to do namah' what we should do
then is actually you might say sort of
erotic promiscuity not necessarily
having sex with all the beautiful bodies
but certainly appreciating them we see
one beautiful body that we're attracted
to we enjoy its its charms it's it's you
know attractions the things about it
that we find beautiful and then we look
at another beautiful body and we say
that body is beautiful as well and then
we can move on to yet another and
another and another and it's possible
for us to go through an entire
succession of beautiful bodies in this
way at a certain point we should start
to become aware if only in an implicit
way that there is there's something
common to all these beautiful bodies
maybe we realize that we have a type
right
some people like blonds other people
like like people with dark hair some
people are into redheads and that's you
know pretty simple stuff right there are
other people like them you know people
tall some people like you short you know
different body types different ways
people move you know we could go through
the entire range of sensuous qualities
that are possible and what do Timon is
getting at here is that we're attaining
something important by finding some
thing in common with all these beautiful
bodies other than you know they can fog
a mirror throw light we wanted to to be
something that leads us to the sense of
there being a form of beauty an idea of
beauty but that is at the level merely
of the physical at a certain point we
leave the merely physical beyond and
there is a you might say a quantum leap
here that occurs she says we have to
move from however many beautiful bodies
we have and we can always add more
bodies into the mix to start to
appreciate the beauty of a soul now of
course this is a lot harder to do right
this requires more work it requires two
things to happen one is you have to be
cultivated enough that you can turn away
from just the body and towards the soul
so if all you're doing is looking at
bodies that's not going to happen for
you right this is not the sort of thing
that st. Maxim magazine what do it would
prepare you for what else has to happen
you actually have to find beautiful
souls that you can look at if everybody
around you is you know not necessarily
beautiful or perhaps even as ugly souls
if everybody has nasty personalities
you're not going to be able to find a
beautiful soul of us I suppose you'd
have your own you look at your own soul
but she doesn't talk about that she says
find another who you can see is
beautiful perhaps this could happen
through literature perhaps this could
happen through film I don't think that
that's quite enough for what she has in
mind she seems to you know think that we
need to encounter we need to experience
beautiful souls so that we can start
moving away from just looking at the
body and start appreciating a deeper a
more profound a more rich sort of beauty
the sort of thing that goes on when we
have conversations with a person when we
begin to admire them for the kind of
person that they are when we spend time
with them long enough to see the pattern
of their habits their assumptions their
desires their attitude
that is what what she's calling
appreciating the beauty of the soul now
for many people it would stop there
right we often contrast the person who's
superficial and just looks at the body
and then we talk about you know the
wonderful personality and finding your
your you know your one your life mate
whatever and now you're fulfilled
because you have a beautiful soul and
presumably you a beautiful soul and
everybody's you know great together but
that wasn't where do Thomas stops it's
not romantic love in the sense of you
know a couple that that she is really
focused on that can stand a part of it
friendship can be a part of it but we
need to move beyond something that's
personal that's that's tied to merely
one person or a set of persons and look
at something wider she says we need to
ascend to the level of beauties of
beauty of laws and institutions
arrangements would be another way you
could translate the the term that's
being translated there is institutions
the sorts of things that you know affect
an entire group an entire community
entire society you know in in the autumn
us view and in Plato's view this is
really about a whole city-state a polis
a political community I don't see any
reason why this couldn't be you know
admiring the beauty of some other
institution an educational institution
for example or a religious institution
say you know think about what goes on in
a monastery of course you need a really
good monks in order for that to be the
case because monks quite often you know
can be you know just like the rest of us
irritable with each other but things can
be arranged well so you could talk about
for example seeing the beauty of the
rule of st. Benedict or in her case
she'll talk about you know she's already
talked about the beauty of like kyrgyz's
Spartan Constitution the laws that he
gave them Solon in Athens the the beauty
of of what he introduced you know there
was a lot of injustice in Athens that's
why they brought in Solon to try to
straighten things out by the way things
did not go particularly well for him
because the rich hated him and the poor
hated him and the middle-class didn't
give him the support that he needed what
he gave Athens a wonderful at least for
a while
Constitution and why is it that the
Ottoman wants us to move from the
beautiful souls to the beauty of
institutions or laws because the laws
are in a certain respect intrapersonal
they they cover everybody
they also shape this is a typical Greek
way of looking at things they shape the
souls that live under those laws whether
they realize it or not so by moving to a
higher level of what we might see is
abstraction or depersonalization we're
actually moving to something that has
greater beauty to offer us greater value
we're uncovering something that we can
have an intellectual experience of or
wonder joy and even erotic desire
towards that erotic like you're gonna
have sex with the laws but rather you
you have a desire for understanding
these things for appreciating them for
contemplating them it doesn't stop there
either now she talks about it peace
demise you know the plural of the piston
a knowledge or it's translated sometimes
as Sciences or we might say disciplines
and these knowledge is she doesn't you
know clarify exactly what they are you
know these forms of knowledge would
include for example the virtues justice
for for Socrates you know in many places
it's going to involve knowledge right
wisdom itself is a kind of knowledge
courage turns out to be a kind of
knowledge for for Socrates but it will
also be the other disciplines as well
and why are we moving now from you know
we might call the legal realm to a more
rarefied realm of we could call them
academic departments if it wasn't for
the fact that most academics show very
little of the erotic in the
practice those who really love the body
of knowledge that they have identified
themselves with that they connect
themselves with with as there aren't as
their skill as their discipline they are
tying in with something that has a yet
greater degree of beauty and it's
knowledge that actually allows the laws
and the institutions to have that cosmos
to have that arrangement that order that
beauty that they're able to bring and
then to give that to the soul beyond all
of this there is a thing or we shouldn't
even call it a thing we can't call it an
experience we can't call it anything
other than what it is the beautiful
itself also the good itself that which
is actually beyond all condition
determinate being this is what Plato
refers to in the Republic as the form of
the good and it's possible for us to
have a knowledge of the beautiful as
such but we have to work our way up
through this entire ladder we can't jump
right from loving bodies or even souls
straight into the ocean of the beautiful
that is eternally self same it is
exactly what it is it is truly what it
is all of the things that a certain
sense are not quite what they are even
knowledge for Plato even presumably the
other forms are not as what they are as
the the form of the beautiful it is
beyond all the others you know there are
some metaphorical language all the
language that we have for this sort of
thing is metaphorical she says this is
very wonderful passage whoever has been
initiated so far in the mysteries of
love and has viewed all these aspects of
the beautiful induced succession is that
last drawing near the final revelation
and now Socrates there bursts upon that
wondrous vision at which is the very
soul of the beauty he has toiled so long
for it is an everlasting loveliness
which neither comes nor goes which
neither flowers nor fades for such
beauty is the same on every hand
the same then as now here as there this
way is that way the same to every
worshipper as it is to every other
notice we've gone from the more
particularized all the way up to what is
there for everything and everybody if
they are actually attuned to it even you
know laws and institutions although they
apply to many people they're not
Universal even knowledge is don't have
the sort of universality that this does
she goes on and she says nor well his
vision of the beautiful take the form of
a face or of hands or anything that is
of the flesh it will be neither words
nor knowledge nor something that exists
in something else such as a living
creature or the earth or the heavens or
anything that is but subsisting of
itself and by itself in an eternal
oneness well every lovely thing partakes
of it in such sort that however much the
parts may wax and wane it will neither
be more nor less but still the same
inviolable whole she suggests that when
we reach this point of grasping this we
will not be content with any other
beauty because the sort of relative
ization will have taken place this is
what is most beautiful nothing can
compare to it it is beyond comparison
even with these we see this at different
points in the ascent by moving to the
beautiful soul and especially moving to
the laws of institutions we appreciate
beautiful bodies but we appreciate them
for what they are just bodies even
beautiful Souls we appreciate that those
limited things wonderful because they're
persons but still condition even
knowledge --is which we're playing oh
you know pretty important right that's
really far up there that can't be
compared to this you notice and I wrote
these four these five things here we're
talking about an ascent through eros
through love it requires some sort of
guide or perhaps a lucky
a coincidence for a person to make it up
this ladder to the beautiful but the
driving force behind this is always eros
there is an ascent right you don't start
out here or here
you start out down here because this is
where we are as human beings originally
and we have to make it up one grade at a
time there is a liberation that takes
place at each level once you have moved
away from beautiful bodies to the
beautiful soul beautiful bodies can no
longer take you in the same way that
they used to likewise you know beauties
of laws and institutions you realize
that the whole matters more than the
mere part a relation of participation
we've realized that what makes for
beautiful souls is the fact of these
beautiful laws and institutions which
themselves participate in the knowledge
which participates in the beautiful
itself all of this including beautiful
bodies participates in the form of the
beautiful that is beyond being itself
finally contemplation at each of these
stages there is a activity of
contemplation that cannot be rushed that
cannot be gained that cannot be hacked
in any way one has to do the work to
move from beautiful bodies to beautiful
Souls it doesn't do any good to just put
on the airs and you know this isn't one
of those fake it till you make it sort
of things if you don't grasp the beauty
of a soul you don't grasp the beauty of
a soul and you can't make it any further
if you can't grasp the beauty of
institutions and it sits contemplative
activity that that is able to make us do
that you're just not going to get up you
know any further up the ladder which by
the way it's not a bad thing if you
can't make it all the way up to the top
it's just not as good as this in Plato's
mind and you're missing out on something
beautiful bodies in this account are
still good there's still a goodness
there it's just it's one that's kind of
you know relative it's one that doesn't
compare to all these other great things
but it's the activity of contemplation
that's required to move one from each of
these state
to the next